as Queen Elizabeth presides over an
emergency meeting today over Prince
Harry and Megan Markel's future opinions
in Britain are sharply divided you could
say the royal couple say that they plan
to step back from their roles while some
support their declaration of
independence others question it in an
op-ed in the raw in the Daily Mail royal
biographer penny junior writes that she
fears Prince Harry appears to be on a
quote trajectory of self-destruction she
also writes he quote essentially he's
rejecting his birthright his closest
family and a public role that he seemed
to have embraced and even flourished in
Finney jr. joins us now from London with
more on this story penny it's good to
see you again I want to start with the
your words where you said he appears to
be on a trajectory of self-destruction
that's pretty strong how can you say
that and what exactly do you mean well
what I mean is I've written about Harry
I've I've spoken to him I followed him
I've observed him over his whole life
when was the last time you've spoken to
him I expect a conversation Robert it
was before he met Megan it was probably
about three years ago yeah it's been a
while it's been a while but the Harry
that I have known all those years is not
the Harry that I'm seeing today the
behavior is very uncharacteristic Harry
is was a very cheerful happy happy man
always laughing always joking always
taking the the mickey out of someone
that cheerful charming man seems to have
disappeared and in his place we have an
angry disgruntled really seriously
disgruntled man I think it's so penny he
missed so penny that he's angry and
frustrated by the treatment of his wife
who he loves and adores and his son and
he's very concerned about her safety and
her well-being why wouldn't he be angry
and frustrated about that Gale the the
treatment that Megan has had at the
hands of our press really it's it's not
as as it's not as devastating as I have
seen over many a hand it out
many other celebrities it is you know
the press I mean if there have been
comparisons with he has compared her
treatment with the treatment that his
mother received from the press there is
truly there is no comparison when Diana
was being pursued by the press and when
they were feasting on her private life
and digging everywhere the the British
media absolutely lost its moral compass
but after her death a new code of
conduct was drawn up for the British
newspapers and the press have abided by
and large by those rules since then they
are way way more restrained than they
were but but of course it's always
hurtful I mean you will know you're in
the public eye I'm in the public eye
when somebody doesn't like you they say
so with no holds barred or the press
will will criticize you and it's hurtful
and I think that Megan has it she's a
sensitive girl she's a lovely girl the
British love her this is what what is so
frustrating Harry and she seemed to be
believing that we we don't love them we
do love them they are fantastic they
arrived you know like they were there
were a golden couple they were
sprinkling fairy dust everywhere they
were in danger that's about shining
William and Kate but penny you also
write that that Harry has has long
struggled with what it means to be a
royal and and that he himself has spoken
openly about being close to a complete
breakdown at points so so why does this
seem so out of character to you before
it was married to Megan yes no Harry
certainly throughout his childhood and
his youth he struggled with being a
royal he wanted to be plain Harry Wales
but he then went into the army and he
fought in Afghanistan he he he changed
he was a changed character this troubled
boy troubled young man who was drinking
too much and and not taking care of
himself he with the army the discovery
that he was so brilliant
flying Apache helicopters he became a
different character and he understood
with the Invictus games which he stole
from America the idea he discovered that
he was able to put together a show like
that within a year the space of a year
he could do that because he was HRH
Prince Harry no Harry Wales could never
ever have done that however brilliant
the idea hey I want to circle back to
the the treatment of Megan by the
tabloids area in the UK in your op-ed
you say that racism has not been a
factor you don't see it as a factor but
we just took a quick search this morning
we found numerous examples of really
questionable phrasing headlines
referring to her as straight out of
Compton a reference to a rap lyric she
has exotic DNA and other piece said
another described her mother as a
dreadlocked african-american lady from
the wrong side of the tracks and then of
course there's that infamous news a BBC
reporter who was fired for tweeting an
image of the Royal baby as a chimp
that's just a quick list that we put
together this morning so how can you say
that race is not a factor here I don't
believe race is a factor I'm sorry I I
really don't look at the way I mean
there of course there are some idiots
around some and there are some racists
around you know we all know that but but
look at the reception that Megan had
when she arrived here we took her to our
hearts the British were thrilled about
her marrying into the royal family and
they were thrilled because she was
mixed-race that was one real plus have
you not heard that have you did you
check in with any black Britons before
you made that determination I hear what
you're saying and I and I know that
there are some people you know that
there are many people in this country
who who are black or who are of color
who feel that they are in a racist
society equally there are other people
who are also of colour who do not feel
they're in the racist society it depends
upon your personal experience personal
experience to have your baby portrayed
as a chimp and it says what a couple
leaving the hospital
it's very hurtful and that is in fact
very race
of course it is I'm not denying that
sorry I'm not speaking I'm not trying to
defend things like that I'm absolutely
not
what I'm saying is that I think that the
overweening sentiment of the British
public was was to be enthusiastic about
Megan to welcome her we want it I mean
she came into the royal family and and
because she was of color it made a whole
lot of colored people in our country
suddenly find that the monarchy was
relevant for them well it certainly
seems to have taken a turn it'll be
interesting to see how this how this big
meeting turns out today we're all very
hopeful yeah well it's a win-win but I I
really hope we don't lose them yes I do
too
Pandi thank you very much
you